all right honey and bandit
honey and bandit uh where did you guys
grow up where are you from originally uh
originally uh york pa
i'm from dallas texas you're from dallas
yeah
and tell me about your families
honey you you had mom and dad um mom and
dad separated before i turned one
and then they had their significant
others and that's pretty much how it's
been my whole life how would you
describe your childhood in general um
childhood wasn't bad it was uh really
interesting actually my dad always tried
to like
get me involved like sports and stuff
like that my mom tried to put me in a
dress when she came back around
um
it was just always always into something
always playing games always outside
just always hanging out my dad was
actually my best friend growing up funny
enough
and then the older i got we kind of like
you know grew apart
but yeah um my mom
she was in and out of my life a lot but
when she's there she's very supportive
and she helps when she can but
it's um
they're an interesting people why was
your mom in and out of your life
um mainly she had a lot of herself stuff
going on
like when she came back
uh it was great i actually moved in with
her for a while
and then she went to school and she has
like a learning disability so she went
to like the special school and she had
to stay there
so i was about like
14 15 when she had to leave again
and like it like it really broke my
heart and like i hold i held like a lot
of resentment for it because i like at
the time i was so young
i didn't really understand it
but you know i get it now you know you
do what you have to do
and she was just trying to better
herself
so i mean
she was doing her thing i guess
and bandit
your parents
um divorced when i was like five years
old
father was a super bad alcoholic
abuse it physically
pretty much taught me how to raise my
kids because
i mean i just learned how not to raise
my kids you know so pretty much i do
everything the opposite of how he did
i'm really supportive of him he was a
pretty good dad honestly i mean beside
the bad stuff like he he tried to
support as best as he could you know he
whatever
you know i wanted to
to get into like i skateboarded most of
my life and surfed and stuff and and he
was always like you know trying to get
me into like real sports or whatever but
uh but he still supported it and um
my mom is
super narcissistic
like she just i mean i love her to death
i do she's a great woman but she is just
her biggest fan
and it's it's hard to deal with like
especially from somebody who like
self-loathes themselves as much as i do
um
dealing with that is kind of hard you
know
very different personality yeah yeah
it's like night and day different yeah
and how do you guys first get introduced
to drugs hard drugs
um hard about 16 and really it was my
self-interest like i was just kind of
curious so you know the whole
cat that was it
curiosity killed the cat that one yeah
um
uh funny enough actually i read about it
a lot and that's what really like piqued
my interest
uh because my my parents none of them
were like alcoholics or you know drugs
or any of that so um
it was really my self-interest
and i just the people that i found
myself around i pretty much told them
like hey you know it's either i'm going
to do it with you or i'm going to do it
with somebody else
and i call them like my brothers
but i'm the only child so
they were like man you pulled that line
on us like really
and i was like what and they're like we
that's what we said to each other and i
was like oh all right so um yeah heroin
was like the first thing i really got
into
and uh i went right to ivy i actually
didn't
nose or ate or none of that stuff like
straight iv
and um yeah she went straight hard in
the paint
such a crazy story
um i was because i had um
i went to this party when i was younger
and
they had they told me it was like
vicodin and percocet and stuff like that
and i actually i blew them and when i
did it all the blood vessels in my face
broke and in my eyes and yeah it was i
don't know what happened other than a
reaction or something
and ever since then i was like nothing's
ever going to my nose again
so
right to iv
and then um
from 16
to 27 i've only had about a year of
sobriety
so rather than trying to hide some
childhood trauma it sounds like maybe
you just you just got addicted to a drug
yeah yeah yeah i mean like nowadays i
mean like i've had bad stuff happen to
me in my life it's not a victim thing
for drugs for me it's you know i i do
enjoy the rush i do like getting high
but if i could get clean if i had
insurance if i had somebody there that's
like hey you know it's all right the
detox you know and the detox is the big
thing you know going through all that
pain and just i have seizures and it's
just
it's the detox it really is i mean it
it sucks and i've been through it
multiple times i just i
can't
kick it
you know i've tried without anything
i've tried without methadone suboxone
i've tried on suboxone and methadone
and it's just nothing
nothing really it's the pain like the
the physical pain you know
it just didn't
didn't do it for me so i just kept going
back that's what i knew how old do you
know 27 27 and abandoned how old are you
i'm 36 36 and you you first got
introduced to harder drugs when
um what i i jokingly say it all the time
to honey that heroin saved my life
in the sense of i was a really bad
alcoholic and actually had cirrhosis by
the time i was like 25
and
then i switched it up and uh i had bouts
of it like from being a kid like 16 17
18 19 20 like around there
i had i had done like like you know
opiates and coke and all that [ __ ] and
um then i was actually off of it for
like 12 years
and
almost 12 years and then
but but but i drank like heavily that
whole 12 years again
and same thing i ended up you know my
liver started crapping out on me again
and so i just i went back to what i knew
you know and i started getting high
again
and um
it's the same thing it's not like not
like i'm you know not blaming like my
childhood or anything on it that's not
the case it's just
i don't know any other way of living
um
like sober living is not my thing the
only time i've ever been sober is
whenever i've been to like
prison um
and i mean that's just not enjoyable so
i think like that maybe that's
the reason why i keep going so hard with
it is because just i think like just
being so like in that state of sobriety
like
just reminds me of all that and just
like i'd rather just not think about it
so both of you are currently using
fentanyl yeah
yeah
amongst others
amongst others too yeah what other drugs
are you playing around with
what do you got
trash can
how long have you stayed in kensington
uh we've only been here for like a
couple months actually yeah so um
not too long what do you think of it
it's [ __ ] crazy out here it's a crazy
city
it's really crazy it's it's like you
know it's it's a lot like skid row you
know but it's it is predominantly white
so you've you've stayed on skid row
before yeah and it's it's
i mean it's pretty much the same yeah
it's very similar to skid row just
mostly white people whereas yeah we're
skid rows predominantly black yeah
we joke around a lot though because we
say you know like it's philly's so dirty
and stuff like that but we're always
like you know it's because it's so dirty
we love it though because it's so dirty
yeah i mean is there something about
this
this lifestyle that
works for you that that
resonates with you that you feel like
you fit in here or something
not really for me i mean i i mean i know
that looked at like as
as crazily like like hometowns like
small towns like people are like
yeah those
neck looking at some guy with his face
tattooed and because it's you know in
smaller areas it's just not that common
but here it's like there's like 15 year
olds with face tattoos you know i went
into the store the other day and i don't
have my id and i tried to buy a pack of
cigarettes and the lady was asking for
it and i was like man i was like really
i was like i got face tattoos and she's
like you know honey you know there's 15
year olds with face tattoos i was like
a point
philly's a crazy city
i love it for that i i i i call it the
northern l.a
i think that's just been my thing for
like a while now it just feels like that
because you do have like the poshy parts
you know
you traveled around about it yeah what
other cities have you been to uh dallas
la seattle
uh like west palm florida
orlando
i mean i've been all up and down the u.s
so you you like it here
it's
it
oddly enough feels like home he wanted
to get out of florida so bad i was like
well you know i'm from pennsylvania
i'd never been so i was like yeah let's
do it
we actually met in florida at his shop
where do you stay when you're in
kensington
um out by like opal yeah we live off of
opel yeah right now opal street so you
have
an apartment or you have no we're just
crashing in somebody's pad yeah yeah
yeah i don't actually have a place right
now right like we i lost everything
yeah uh we when we first when i first
brought him to philly uh we had a car
and then we went to center city or
something like that yeah we spent the
night in a hotel and it got stolen yup
came out and was like um
all right so i guess um
feet is where it's going to be walking
and public transportation
is it easier or harder as a couple to be
out here homeless i think it's easier
yeah because you got one another
really i mean
when like if i have something that's
like the last you know we'll i'll split
it with him or i'll give it to him or if
i only have like two left i'll give him
one if he's not feeling good and he does
the same for me yeah i mean we we do say
you know it's only drugs but at the end
of the day like we do need it like to
function properly you know i mean
because without it it's bad
it's really bad
like you i mean like you pretty much you
just sit in a ball
explain
to us what it's like to well like the
detox the detox or just not would it be
dopestick not have what you need
uh
well
you you want to move because your body
is like it's constantly moving you're
shaking you're sweating you're restless
but like you just you have no energy
like no energy and violently throwing up
pooping everywhere and then you get this
awful sharp tongue like well if you're
like us yeah we get into it we really do
i mean like it's not like that razor
blades on our mouths like i mean it's
not physical you know but we we do got
razor blade tongues and we do get into
it but i think we'll hurt each other's
feelings really bad
but we also know at the end of the day
that it is what it is and as soon as
i i mean 99 times out of a hundred you
know if i see that she's hurt by
something that i said i immediately
backpedal and i'll tell her you know i'm
sorry
she because she's my best friend you
know she's my second half
she's my one and only
i don't i don't want to hurt this person
she's my person
my person my favorite human
absolutely you guys have been together
how long
uh like a little over two and a half
years now yeah
i got out of a really rough marriage
it was terrible
yeah i'm like i didn't even want to get
married again
but i met her and do either of you have
children
i don't have any um
like i can't actually have children
no and um i was told at a a younger age
that i couldn't
but um when i told my parents they're
like oh it's the drug use it's the drug
use and i was like well that's kind of
funny because when i was younger and i
was going to obgyn
like i just uh was it i first like got
my period there like they do all that
stuff on you and everything
and um
they told me i couldn't have kids
so i don't really know the reason why
i mean at this point i probably think
drugs definitely have
something to do with it
um
yeah but it's deeper than that i'm
pretty sure she has endometriosis i i
grew up with a sister who has it and she
has a lot of the same symptoms i mean
there's like dead life dave like day for
day spot on for spot on it's the same
exact thing that my sister's gone
through so
and then um when we were actually when
we were down in florida i ended up
having a miscarriage
and
um it really hit home
like really hard
and um i blame myself
you know
especially when um
when you're told it can't happen and
then it does and then you lose it
you feel responsible do you think that
was because of drugs
i mean i probably i mean it probably had
something to do with it
for sure i mean it didn't help i'll you
know
definitely
but um
yeah it definitely didn't help
and
you know it just
it sucks
if you got pregnant again would you
would that be motivation enough to stop
using i mean if i if somebody told me
today you know hey i will get you into a
facility
and you know we'll make sure that you
know you're not in pain will help you
come off of it and everything
sign me up yeah heartbeat you know and
tell me i don't have a 100 000 dead
after it you know
but i would do it in a heartbeat too
absolutely
absolutely but trying to come off these
drugs by yourself it's horrible and
especially i mean
even with if you're with somebody or
you're alone
it sucks and all like the
recovery stuff you're not alone you're
not alone you feel alone yeah no they
say you're not alone but you're [ __ ]
alone
people look at you different they hear
that you jam needles in your arms and
they're just like oh you're one of those
people it's like you know [ __ ] you jack
like first off yeah
but i mean i don't even get in my
feelings about it anymore what do you
think most
people that are not in this lifestyle
don't understand about drug addiction
one once you're on it it's
to come off yeah to come off is the big
thing
um
if it definitely [ __ ] with your your
mental
a lot you know
because you start you start thinking
like you know like this shoulda woulda
cut us
like if i didn't do it
or like if i could get off of it or like
how differently your life would be if
you never even ran into it
you know
um
but
as far as like you know what you have to
do to get them it changes every day
yeah you know
um
it's not always
the whole prostitution and stuff like
that it it's really like what you can do
like
i i was joking about it the other day
actually with a friend and i said people
find like their own finesse
like you find like your own groove
really of like what works for you and
what doesn't and you try everything
you do she's a lot nicer than i am
because i'll rob steal and cheat i don't
give a [ __ ] about people anymore
i just don't i mean i try to be nice to
people but
after a while you just stop caring
and really people are [ __ ] to you
anyways like we're not like
but to people that use drugs is it
pretty much just every man for himself
out there on the streets in kensington
yeah for sure yeah it's crazy like i
mean what yesterday we seen it the um
this guy he was like he was out like out
oh yeah yeah yeah this dude was homeless
man and these these these crack heads
like went up and stole all of his [ __ ]
they tried to wake him up
like three or four times the guy kept
going back out and they were like well
[ __ ] them and they just went and took
like all of this food all this clothes
everything and i was just like this is
[ __ ] up out here
like just rummaging through all this
stuff like it's exactly like skid row
and it's totally like
every dog for himself what kind of
emotions do you guys go through
oh it's up and down
up and down one minute you're you know
like you're just you're just there
you're just here you're just existing
we're generally pretty happy though yeah
which
i think it's kind of kind of a miracle
really but uh are there some benefits to
this lifestyle
no not really
lack of responsibility you don't have to
get it for work tomorrow you don't have
to
um but you do
yeah i mean it's you might not have a
nine to five but i do
have to work
what does your typical day look like
it
changes from day to day i mean you could
be you could be
stealing one day the next day you could
hit a hit 500 on a scratch off yeah i
mean or scam somebody out of their
[ __ ] credit card funds whatever
if somebody's dumb enough to give it to
you then then that's that's their
problem
it's sad to be like that and i know that
but after a while it's
and it happens to you over and over too
it becomes so regular that you just get
jaded
and it's just
you don't you don't you don't have any
qualms or quarrels about it anymore
because you know that the next guy down
the line you know would do it to you
yeah
period
what are you afraid of
what do you worry about
that my kids are gonna turn out like me
that's my biggest fear
i have a great relationship with them
like i
you know every unfortunately they're
down in florida with my ex-wife but um
does your son know you're a drug addict
no no um my oldest he's he's got an idea
but
he hasn't he doesn't have confirmation
of that and actually i was just talking
to him this morning
i mean so we you know we we keep in
pretty close contact
those little ones so cute
beans yeah
he looked like a buddy of mine that
passed away
his nickname was beans so i nicknamed my
son beans after my buddy that passed so
and now especially because he had to get
glasses so he looks like just like you
just like me
just like him
that poor kid
i mean poor kid
do you think
anything about your personalities have
changed from living this lifestyle
probably just hardened a little bit
a little rougher on the edges
but i mean otherwise like we usually
have smiles on our faces yeah most days
where i'm kicking him in the ass to get
him to smile
yeah i go through it sometimes from not
seeing my kids but she's she's there for
me to pick me up and
we're there for each other we gotta be
nobody else is gonna be
nobody else is gonna be there for me
when my head's down he is
if you had your lives to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
nothing
nothing not a damn thing i don't regret
it i don't regret a thing
i would have probably got cleaner a
little bit sooner but
otherwise really i can't even say that
because
i'm who i am right now
because of everything
and if i wasn't who i am and she wasn't
who she was and maybe you wouldn't have
approached us so yeah
hey
do you have friends out here yeah
yeah yeah like real friends or just
i'd say probably two street
acquaintances
i would say they're more acquaintances
but i mean they've shown us a lot of
love
a lot like a lot more than what most
people that i've known for years and
years and years there are some
good-hearted people out here there
really is yeah
yeah there's it's insanity right i mean
we ran into them because of you know
doing drugs yeah but it turned into i
mean like we still have like you know we
still realize like the line between you
know business and friendship right
but um
definitely
they showed us a little bit more to like
to their side they were a lot warmer
yeah
than what i expected for sure
yeah
how do you guys support yourself
financially
however we can however
really um
it's hard to put a label on it because
whenever you get money from so many
different things
yeah there's not really one thing that
you can
definitively say
honey do you ever get pressured to do
sexual favors and things like that oh no
i'll kill somebody it's happened i'll
[ __ ] kill somebody
it's happened
you know i'm not gonna sit here and lie
and say that it hasn't you know um
but
as of like today to now
it's not what i have to do
you know yeah it's not gonna be what she
has to do
we'll figure something different what
would you say is the most important
lesson you guys have learned
that the dare program did not work
not even
it did not work no
we we all let him down
saying no to drugs doesn't work yeah no
you can only say no so many times until
you say yes
true
yeah um
that's terrible it is
but um i don't i really don't know
kensington is really just a
very very treacherous little community
isn't it oh it's so weird tell me about
staying on kensington or is it is it in
kensington or on kensington i guess it's
on kensington square the fearsome square
is that park that's like the epicenter
yeah that's neil needle park
yeah that's what it's labeled
i mean there's it's like and then all
around it too it's not just the park
it's everything around them
blocks and blocks and blocks
yeah yeah every direction you can just
i mean even like where we live we're
we're out right now we're like what two
and a half three miles out it's like out
by tempe and everybody's still you hear
that the dope dealers like calling it
out yeah like calling out their stamps
or whatever and i'm like holy [ __ ] like
yes it's the entire community seems to
revolve around drugs yeah and it's not
just a few blocks it's not just no it's
like a huge part of the city yeah
everything and the cops
you know like they control it
they're the ones who are letting the
[ __ ] in they're the ones who control
everything and they act like it was
spread out for miles in every direction
yeah and i mean like you're gonna sit
here and tell me that you're doing
everything you can for this city
when you're the ones making the bus
you're the ones making
it possible for these things to be on
the street you're the ones letting these
people go you're the ones taking them in
what do you wish the city would do
just legalize the [ __ ] already
get it over with it's such a problem
already and all it's doing is just
becoming more of a problem regulate it
yeah you know get it done
you know they they do what they can they
have the needle exchange and all that
stuff and that's great yeah they do
down by mcpherson they have um as a
church
and you can get like um they give you
like a whole eggs like the only thing
they don't give you is the drugs yeah
that's crazy they have they have showers
they have bathrooms they have i mean and
there's people down there that haven't
showered in six months and they go to
the bathroom on the streets and it's
like why dude like they have showers
like yeah it's all right there it's all
right there all you the you know just
it's right there just walk a couple
paces you know
i mean you don't have to use dirty rigs
they give you free ones i mean if you
have dirty ones you don't need to leave
them on the street you can bring them in
it's in exchange
do you think some of these people have
just seem to have a death wish
yeah for sure
probably but i can't speak for them
you know
but i mean i don't know we've seen that
one dude on pcp stripping down naked and
pissing in the street that was strange
that guy he was having a grand old time
he was like
his dick in his hand and everything's
just pissing in the air i've heard
stories about
like certain like dealers that will have
a batch of fentanyl that's particularly
strong or you know which would make it
more dangerous
and people will just hunt them down to
get get it yeah
i don't doubt it's almost like they're
trying to kill themselves i don't doubt
it i mean i've i've i mean i don't know
if it's them trying to kill themselves
or if they're just so tired of the junk
yeah there's a bunch of shitty dope
around the city
it's actually an elephant tranquilizer
and if you missed you'll get nasty
abscesses yeah i got one in my hand
right now i have one on my foot it's
gross i got one in my foot too and it's
gross it's really it's like it's to the
bone yeah it's disgusting
but yeah they mix down the uh the
fentanyl with with elephant tranquilizer
because it just drops you down and does
what it's supposed to do it gets you
hooked
and that's what actually makes the come
down even worse is that the tranq i mean
the fentanyl is bad enough but the train
just gets you so sick you start
hallucinating whenever you're coming off
of it
it doesn't really get you high it just
puts you out
well i mean it does i mean it's not it
gets you high but yeah you get you high
you feel the rush and everything but it
puts you down yeah and um
it just makes it stronger
and it makes it harder to get off of it
yeah
yeah like um
like uh if i do a shot or something like
um like i'll hit my neck
and i can as soon as i do it i can feel
it in the back of my throat
like it's like a cool rush and like hit
in my throat that's like where we're
both at now we don't have any other
veins i can't go anywhere else all we
have is the carotid and the jugular to
hit
yeah and i can't i can't go on my side
mine's all [ __ ] up you know it's hard
oh yeah and that's another thing too
your veins will start to harden
like and even if you do or like if you
do coke if you iv coke it'll harden your
veins
and like a great like my my arms are
like
they went down but they they get swollen
and mine are disgusting right now yeah
they get numb and actually i had a i had
a hair tie on and i fell asleep with it
the other night and i woke up and my arm
was like killing me and i took it off
and it looked i had this like the line
the line it made my arm look all fat and
weird it was gross
yeah it's crazy
for sure would you guys describe
yourselves as happy
absolutely most of the time
i mean we go i argue through my
depressive issues but i mean that's
that's strictly on my own i i have like
ptsd man from like being in prison and
being shot at and [ __ ] like that so and
i just never dealt with my drama really
i just push it i just put it in a box
and shove it to the back of my head and
every once in a while it comes up but
she's doing better with it
she is
since she's met me i've i've dug a lot
of crap out of there yeah you have she's
doing good she's doing a lot better now
a lot more she's turned from
some hard nose to
more softer
to more of a softer human
and in turn she's done the same with me
i was really shut out emotionally for a
long time and uh
and she just she warmed it up
you know it's amazing amazing what the
right person can do for you i always
tell them you can tell me anything i'll
never judge you i'll never judge you for
anything that's true and i don't
i mean how am i going to judge my best
friend the person that picks me up the
person that listens to all my [ __ ]
you know
just can't
can't move
i judge you all the time ah [ __ ] you
all right honey and bandit thank you so
much for sharing your stories yeah
absolutely i wish you guys the best of
luck out there thank you so much thanks
so much thank you
you